[la musique]
puis-je accepter les changements comme les nôtres
Actions
non je ne peux pas oui je peux te contacter et
pour vous offrir, à vous et à mon peuple, mon
relation amicale
les bons allemands aiment conduire
étaient amis et la catégorie ne facturera pas encore
professeur donc moi tout l'été près
en quelque sorte pas une expression quand ce n'était pas
examen des marins j'étais un enseignant j'ai enseigné
J'ai différentes nationalités
il n'y avait pas de différence stylos c'est allemand
Ukrainien quelqu'un moi au box-office tout manuellement
jamais de menaces non comment
dire la mise bas du bracelet intempestif
pas de nationalité
trop d'attention ici dans l'ouest
étant donné
Contribution américaine et trop peu
votre abnégation est notre chère
l'armée soviétique libère, je tiens à
total tout l'ouest tous les pays occidentaux
surtout depuis maintenant qu'il y a un tel
ville à ce sujet et dis-moi lequel dit non
notre monument de parshev
éruption destructrice en pologne en particulier
Les poteaux se détachent, je sors lesquels
passé pologne run varsovie et prix de l'eau
j'ai vu tout ça comme donner plus souvent
âge poney j'ai vu le score comme un ennemi
a été fabriqué par l'Union soviétique russe
soldats
et maintenant c'est déformé par le levier de vitesses de tout
contre la résistance
les Russes